you are the director of the nih
you are dr anthony fauci's technically
his boss yep
you have stood behind him you have
supported him
just like you did already in this
conversation
it is painful for me to see division and
distrust
but
many people in politics and elsewhere
have called for anthony fauci to be
fired
when there are such calls of distrust in
public about a leader like anthony fauci
who should garner trust do you think
he should be fired
absolutely not
to do so would be basically to give
the opportunity
for those who want to make up stories
about anybody
to destroy them there is nothing
in the ways in which tony fauci has been
targeted that is based upon truth
how could we then
accept those cries for his firing as
having legitimacy
it's a circular argument they've decided
they don't like tony so they make up
stuff and they twist
comments that he's made about things
like gain a function where he's
referring to the very specific gain of
function that's covered by this policy
and they're trying to say he lied to the
congress that's simply not true
they don't like the fact that tony
changes the medical recommendations
about what to do with covet 19 over the
space of more than a year
and they call that flip-flopping and you
can't trust the guy because he says one
thing last year and one thing this year
well the science has changed
delta variant has changed everything you
don't want him to be saying the same
thing he did a year ago that would be
wrong now it was the best we could do
then people don't understand that or
else they don't want to understand that
so when you basically whip up a largely
political argument against a scientist
and hammer at it over and over again to
the point where he now has to have 24 7
security to protect him against people
who really want to do violence to him
for that to be a reason to say that then
he should be fired is to hand the evil
forces the victory i will not do that
yet there's something difficult i'm
going to try to express to you
so it may be your guitar playing
uh it may be something else
but there's a humility to you it may be
because you're a man of god
there's a humility to you
that
garners trust
and
when you're in a leadership position
representing science especially in
catastrophic events like the pandemic
it feels like as a leader you have to go
far above and beyond
your usual duties
and i think there's no question that
anthony fauci has delivered on his
duties
but it feels like he needs to go above
as a science communicator and if there's
a large number of people that are that
are distrusting him
it's also his responsibility to garner
their trust to gain their trust
as a as a person who's the face of
science do you are you torn on this the
responsibility of anthology of yourself
to represent science
not just the communication of advising
what should be done
but
giving people hope giving people trust
in science
and alleviating division
do you think that's also a
responsibility of a leader or is that
unfair to ask
i think the best way you give people
trust is to tell them the truth
and so they recognize that when you're
sharing information it's the best you've
got at that point and tony fauci does
that at every moment
i don't think him expressing more
humility
would change the fact that they're
looking for a target of somebody to
blame uh to basically distract people
from the failings of their own political
party
maybe i'm less targeted not because of a
difference in oh the way in which i
convey the information i'm less visible
if tony were out of the scene and i was
placed in that role i'd probably be
seeing a ratcheting up of that same
targeting
i would like to believe
that if tony fauci said
that when i originally made
recommendations not to wear masks
that was given on the on our best
available data
and now we know that is a mistake
so admit with humility that there's an
error that's not
that's not actually correct
but that's that's a statement of
humility and i would like to believe
despite the attacks
he would win a lot of people over with
that
so a lot of people as you're saying
would use that see that here we go
here's that dr anthony fauci making
mistakes how can we trust him at
anything i believe if he was
the sp that public display of humility
to say that i made an error
that would win a lot of people over
that's my that's kind of
my sense to face the fire of the attacks
from politics you have to like
politicians will attack no matter what
but the question is the people
would you to win over the people that
the biggest concern i've had
is that there was this
distrust of science that's been brewing
and i'm
maybe you can correct me but i'm a
little bit unwilling to fully blame the
politicians because politicians play
their games no matter what
it just feels like this was an
opportunity
to inspire people with the power of
science the development of the vaccines
no matter what you think of those
vaccines is one of the greatest
accomplishments in the history of
science it is indeed
and
the fact that that's not inspiring
listen i host a podcast
whenever i say positive stuff about the
vaccine i get to hear
a lot of different opinions i bet you do
the fact that i do is a big problem to
me because it's an incredible
an incredible accomplishment of science
and so i
yeah i i i'm sorry but i have to put
responsibility on the leaders
even if it's not their mistakes that's
what the leadership is that's what
leadership is you take responsibility
for the situation i wonder if there's
something that could have been done
better
to
give people hope
that science will save us as opposed to
science will divide us
i think you have more confidence
in the ability to get beyond our current
divisions
than i do after seeing just how deep and
dark they have become
tony fauci has said multiple times the
recommendation about not wearing masks
was for two reasons
a shortage of masks which were needed in
hospitals and
a lack of realization early in the
course of the epidemic
that this was a virus that could
heavily infect asymptomatic people
as that changed he changed now did he
make an error no he was making a
judgment based on the data available at
the time but he certainly made that
clear over and over again
it has not stopped uh those who would
like to demonize him from saying well he
just flip-flopped
um he you can't trust a guy he says one
thing today and one thing tomorrow
well masks is a tricky one so it is a
tricky one early on i'm a co-author and
a paper one of one of many but this was
a survey paper overlooking the
the evidence
uh it's a summary of the evidence we
have for the effectiveness of masks
it seems that
it's difficult to do rigorous scientific
study on masks it is difficult
there's a lot of philosophical and
ethical questions i want to ask you but
within this
it's back to your words and anthony
fauci's words
when you're dealing with so much
uncertainty
and so much potential uncertainty about
how catastrophic this virus is in the
early days
and knowing that each word you say may
create panic
how do you communicate science with the
world
it's a philosophical it's an ethical
it's a practical question there was a
discussion about masks a century ago
and that too led to panic
so
i mean i'm trying to put myself in the
mind in your mind in the mind of anthony
fauci in those early days knowing that
there's limited supply masks
like what do you say
do you fully convey the uncertainty of
the situation
of the
of the challenges of the supply chain
or do you say that masks don't work
that's a complicated calculation
how do you make that calculation
it is a complicated calculation
as a scientist your temptation would be
to give a full brain dump of all the
details
of the information about what's known
and what isn't known and what
experiments need to be done
most of the time that's not going to
play well in a sound bite on the evening
news so you have to kind of distill it
down to a recommendation that is the
best you can do
at that time with the information you've
got
you